I'm thinking about getting a life
insurance because I have a mortgage and
I have a young son and another baby on
the way and so if anything were to
happen to me I want them to at least be
able to pay off the mortgage and then
maybe have some money left over for
college and to live and and whatever
else and so I went to the insurance
companies I said I want to get them 1
million dollar policy and I what I'm
actually getting a quote on is a term
life policy which is really I just care
about the next 20 years after those 20
years hopefully I can pay off my
mortgage and it'll be money saved up and
hopefully my kids would kind of at least
have maybe gotten to college or I would
have had saved up enough money for
college so that's why I'm willing to do
a term life policy the other option is
to do a whole life policy where you
could pay a certain amount of per year
for the rest of your life and at any
point you die you get you get the
million dollars in a term life I'm only
going to pay $500 per year for the next
20 years if at any point over those 20
years I die my family gets a million at
the 21st year I have to get a new policy
and since I'm going to be older and I'd
have a higher chance of dying at that
point then it's probably going to be
more expensive for me to get insurance
but I really am just worried about the
next 20 years but what I want to do in
this video is think about given these
numbers that have been quoted to me by
the insurance company what do they think
that my odds of dying are over the next
20 years so what I want to think about
is the probability of Sal's death in 20
years based on based on what the people
at the insurance company are telling me
or at least what is what's the maximum
probability of my death in order for
them to make money and the way to think
about it or one way to think about it
kind of a back-of-the-envelope way is to
think about what's the total premiums
they're getting over the life of this
policy divided by how much they're
insuring me for so they're getting $500
$500 times 20 years is equal to that's
$10,000 over the life of this policy and
they are insuring me they're insuring me
for 1 million dollars
they are insuring me for $1,000,000
so they're getting let's see those zeros
cancel out this zero cancels out they're
getting over the life of the policy
$1.00 in premiums $1.00 in premiums for
every there's only for every $100 for
every $100 in insurance or another way
to think about it let's say that there
were a hundred cells 134 year-olds
looking to get 20-year term life
insurance and they insured all of them
so if you multiply this times 100 if you
multiply this by a hundred you they
would get a hundred dollars in premiums
100 dollars in premiums this is the case
where you have a hundred cells or
hundred people who are pretty similar to
me one hundred one hundred cells they
would get a hundred dollars in premium
and the only way that they could make
money the only way they could make money
is if at most one of those cells or
really just break even if at most one of
those cells were to die so break even
break even if only only one cell dies I
don't like talking about this it's a
little bit morbid so one way to think
about they're getting $1 in premium for
$100 insurance or if they had a hundred
thousand so we've got a hundred dollars
in premium and the only way they would
break even if only one of those cell
dies so what they're really saying is is
that the only way they can break even is
if the probability of Sal dying and then
look next 20 years is less than is or is
less than or equal to one in 100 and
this is an insurance company they're
trying to make money so they're probably
giving these numbers because they think
the probability of me dying is a good
maybe it's one in 200 or it's one in 300
something lower so that they can ensure
a yook one way to think about they could
insure more cells and have and have an
end for every hundred dollars in premium
they have to pay out but either way it's
a back-of-the-envelope way of thinking
about it and it actually makes me feel a
little bit better because one in a
hundred over the next 20 years isn't
isn't too bad